شمس المعاناه تؤذن بصباح جديد صباح يبدا
مختلفه عن اي مكان اخر في العالم
يبدا نحو 72 الف سوري نهارهم هكذا الحطب
لتدفئه الصغار وغسل الملابس على الفطور لا
يتوفر غالبا سوى الخبز
زباله والله يا اخوي وحق الخبز
بالشكل التفاحه نسيناها شكله البرتقاله
نسيناها قرنا الموز ما عاد بدنا نعرف شلون
شكله ريحه اللحم والله العظيم ما تشوفوا
الا بس وقف
الاطفال
بوجوههم البريئه المتسخه نسال من منهم
يستطيعوا ان يقرا هذه الجمله في حدا يعرف
في قرار شو كاتبه هون
انت ولا واحد منكم فايت على المدرسه
ليش ما
رحتوا على المدرسه
ما احد يجينا يطلعنا ما حد يفوتنا على
المدرسه
وعددهم 50,000 وهو ما يثير مخاوف الاداره
المدنيه للرقه التي تواجه قائمه طويله من
المشاكل التي تبدا بالجوع ولا تنتهي باميه
الاطفال
موجوده ضمن هذه المدينه
وعلى التحالف الدولي ومنظمات
الدوليه التفاعل مع هذه
الخطه اللي نستطيع القضاء على هذه المشكله
وتخطط الاداره الذاتيه منذ سنوات لجمع
العشوائيات في ثلاث نقاط رئيسيه ودفع
المنظمات الانسانيه للعمل فيها
توقفت كثيرا وخطت قليله لضعف الامكانيات
كل الحلول التي وضعت هنا لحل مشكله
المخيمات العشوائيه ومنحها صفه المخيمات
المنظمه فشلت حتى الان الاميه تتفشى كما
الفقر والجوع والقهر
او تقرير من احد المخيمات العشوائيه في
مدينه الرقه شمال شرق سوريا جمعه كاش
العربيه